die müsste richtig durchgreifen gegen
die linken chaoten mal ein bisschen
gewalt anwenden
doch nicht
[Musik]
alle bands
jeder nur ein kreuz leute
reinkommen diese freude
[Musik]
was sind ihre drei lieblings religionen
meine ist das kosten turnierplatz 1
platz zwei
das sind um platz drei für mich gibt das
sonst nichts an draußen die beiden ich
bin für keine religion
habe sie tragen auf dem kreuz jetzt
gerade hier ich glaube an die bibel
stehen alle letztlich sagen wir mal auf
der seite des lebens und das ist immer
die seite gott ist alles da danke schön
aber nicht verteilung nicht der
islamische glaube es geht hier um den
gott abrahams isaaks und her gottes
willen natürlich ihr seid aber schon
gegen abtreibung oder wir sind nicht
gegen abtreibungen sind vier abtreibung
selbst auf den stolz darauf mit ihnen
ketzer die müsste richtig durchgreifen
gegen die linken chaoten mal ein
bisschen gewalt anwenden
dass der staat sich verteidigen kann
[Musik]
aber ist es denn mit dem christentum
vereinbart dass man da jetzt darauf
prügelt ich prügel ja nicht wenn die
kennzahlen sollten ja weil sie die
polizei muss ja schließlich die dummheit
ihnen bewusst in den ins gehirn grünen
er heute sind für ihr geschäft tausende
anhänger dabei wie viele davon sind
bewaffnet
wenn sie aber wir kommen auch an wenn ja
wie schon sehen das kann schon tödlich
sein fragen schon mal jesus christus
[Applaus]
wir können ja jetzt bekehrt vielleicht
versuchen sie zu bekehren wir haben
jetzt die chance auge in auge wir sind
ja hier ganz
sichtbar unterwegs für das wofür wir
eintritt wert dann erschossen das
paradies zu kommen ich eher unauffällig
oder sie mit dem ganzen tamtam ihr ich
als landesvorsitzender an den schulen
natürlich haben bessere karten da sind
was ich bin landesvorsitzende von lesben
und schwulen in der union 18 schärfer
bei der falschen demo oder
ich komme von einem satiremagazin habe
ich trotzdem eine realistische chance
nicht in die hölle zu kommen ja die
haben sie auf jeden fall aber wenn sie
jetzt gegen vergütungen sind und gegen
abtreibung was für eine sexualpraktik
würden sie mit den empfehlen wenn ich
einfach nur ein bisschen fern haben will
ein bisschen fanden einfach nur haben
will
das ist
man sollte es nicht nur aus spaß dann
machen
gut dann brauchen wir auch schon mal
keine nummer mehr zu tauschen
[Musik]
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
hallo
hast du scheiße fährt haye